like there's a there's like of course
there's like there's a spectrum you know
i mean there's people that really don't
give a [ __ ]
like to the point that i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm not gonna wash yeah i'm not
gonna wash i'm not gonna bathe i'm not
gonna take care of my [ __ ] because i
don't care about other people whatever
you know i mean
there's to that extent you know what i
mean where you total
total disregard that's unhealthy though
yeah i'm pretty sure no not washing is
like not wash ever but there's a yeah
there's a where it's not gonna be
unhealthy but you know you
yeah
you stink you whoa
you smell like
you're past dude yeah yeah yeah yeah you
do
your due date has come
listen you gotta give a little bit of a
[ __ ]
this is your daily basic [ __ ] that you
have to give here you go society that's
my basic [ __ ] what do you mean i bathe
yeah i wash my booty yeah yeah yeah i
brush my hair
you know what's funny is that you'll see
people with the finest clothes who got
some of the nastiest hygiene that's
always a trick
i'm like [ __ ] say what you want i be
showering all the time i'll be taking
care of my spot my place is semi-clean
like if you come in it don't look like
i'm trying to hide bodies somewhere okay
i take care of my [ __ ] i manage it i see
[ __ ] who outwardly look amazing
you go to their home it's churnable
it is insane to me that's the problem
i'm telling you
oh yeah this [ __ ] don't work and i'm
like okay yeah whatever uh i'll pass by
i'll pass by and then you pass by
yo gp put the three on put the camera
three on
you know when you step in the
[ __ ] house
you take your shoes off because you're
respectable yeah and then you walk two
three steps at the house and you have to
do this
to get the crumbs off your socks
[ __ ] let me put my shoes back on yeah
get out of here yeah let me put my shoes
back on because it's less dirty outside
yes
[Applause]
i don't want to make outside dirty with
your place
[Music]
and i'm gonna have to take off my shoe
when i step outside yeah let me be
considerate of this planet [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] no no no no
absolutely wait you ain't no walking in
my house
and it's like you you step inside people
you step it's not people's apartment and
you're like
you knew i was coming over right
no
you ever walked you ever walked into
somebody's apartment like
does the cat pay rent
the cat difference the campaign not even
that who paying all the bills in this
[ __ ] because all i smell is this
[ __ ] cat he's on the lease
cause you you
you
you're a roommate [ __ ] cat little that
cat does whatever the [ __ ] it was first
and foremost ha ha that i didn't even
see your cat i'm outside your house
[ __ ] it smells like cat
that's wild
there's some of y'all out there you like
pets you shouldn't own them
goddamn
[ __ ]